on ne doit pas on ne doit pas fait ces
deux femmes c'est toujours désolant de
jeter des pins mais parfois il arrive il
y en ait qui soit un peu coupé d' avance
et qui sèche
voici poindre à l'horizon une bonne
occasion de faire un essai rares et à
bhl avec des tranches de pain qu'ils
peuvent dater de 2 3 jours et ceci avec
n'importe quel pin pas spécialement à
pain de campagne
n'importe quel pin de bonne qualité
normale peut faire le pas perdu alors
pour le pain perdu
on aura besoin de 4 personnes 3 e 1 drop
au dessus deux cuillères un verre d'eau
un verre de rhum on va casser on va les
mélanger sans les bars tranquillement
que le gland sans faire de monde voilà
c'est suffisant c'est un peu bruyant et
plus polluante pour parler de trois
rangs du corta ce combat là ne tiendrait
pas il ya des réponses sur le peuple
pour l'être en pet un verre à moutarde
dos un verre à moutarde de rome ou de 9
à 12
moi je préfère les calvados mais je
crois que toute façon les amateurs de
sport préféré le vendre parce que
c'était la vie recettes un petit peu de
sucre depuis hier à soupe
et on mélange voilà à partir de
maintenant une petite trempette de pain
recto et verso
pendant que sa femme une noisette de
beurre
bonjour
voilà on passe de la trempette dans les
métaux verre chaud et lourd
de la trentaine dont les voilà alors oui
une fois les choses mais elle est
épaisse et il ne faut pas que le refus y
ajoute suffisante pour aller faire les
soldes 2010 ensuite on les retournera
d'une minute et en par les vagues voyez
c'est suffisant voilà on est un petit
peu de leye il faut essayer d'aller à
c'est quand même ri parce que si le pain
se délecte d'ailleurs c'est un pas qui
n'est pas très racée et dans le fond il
en arrive à utiliser du pain franchement
franchement rassis il se tient lieu il
faut tenir cinq minutes sans ceux des
veilleurs et si vous voulez l'aromatiser
à votre façon il ya mille façons de
faire le pain perdu mais finalement
c'est très agréable de manger
[Musique]